I'm Timmy alikum and partner at Y
Combinator and one of the things I
helped founders do a lot is prepare to
launch that is what I'm gonna talk to
you about today so I want to change the
way you think about launching so most
people think about launching as
something that you get one shot at but I
so for example I just talked to a team
that's been preparing to launch for six
months they were lovingly trying to get
every pixel perfect on their product
before they shared it with everyone and
now they are stressing over every line
on their landing page and you know
they're trying to line up everything
right with timing but if you're like
most startups you will launch something
no one will care and if it took you six
months to get there your strap is
probably gonna be dead before you get
another chance to launch so in the same
sort of spirit I'd always be shipping I
want you to think about launching a
thing you can continually do I want to
destroy the idea that launching is just
this one moment in time because assuming
you do well and assuming you ship new
products and new features you are never
going to not launching so let's talk
about all the ways that you can launch
here are different opportunities to
launch that we're going to go through
today I'll go through each of these
except press launches we have done a
previous startups lecture on press
launches and I'll share a link to that
and some resources you know after this
but well over most of these and most of
these things are things that you should
be doing while you're in start-up school
so let's talk about first why you want
to continuously launch so before you
even have a fully functioning product
you get a chance to practice your pitch
and you can refine it you can a be test
it and see how people actually respond
to the idea and then once you have an
MVP or you know a very early version of
your product launching through different
channels will give you an opportunity to
see how people will respond to that
early version of the product you know
and then launching two different
channels will help you determine whether
you're even talking to the right users
because you know you might launch on one
channel and get no response you'll
another channel and you'll get a huge
response and so that will help you
identify whether you know you're
identifying the right user for what
you're building so let's talk about some
of the types of launches that you can do
while you're in start-up school and I'm
excited to hear that you know a thousand
of you have launched so far since the
start of startup startup school that's
incredible
so I clicked on ten random startup
school companies from founders who
posted on the forum and only about half
had landing pages so this is what I call
the silent launch and you do not need
anything fancy for this you know all you
need is a domain name your company name
a short description a contact and a call
to action so for example this is a
random startup school company that I
found from a founder who'd posted on the
forum their company is zinc they have
you know a domain name they have their
company name they have their you know
short one-line pitch a short description
and their call to Acton which is get in
touch the call to action can be
something like you know subscribe to our
newsletter or subscribe to hear more
when we launch product hunt for example
has an actual product for pre-launch
companies called ship and it's a way to
collect potential like interest from
potential users so for example this is
something called designer school and it
has a quick intro from the founders a
short description of what the company
does and a call to action which is
subscribe so you know you can go on
product hunt and set up one of these
pages but of course you can also build
your own landing page incredibly quickly
and easily and this should be something
if you don't have one yet that you do
this weekend so the next thing is the
friends-and-family launch so if you're
at ideas stage you can test out your
short pitch on family and friends and
see how they respond and once you have
an MVP do a friends-and-family launch as
quickly as possible so in its earliest
days reddit was shared just among the
founders of their batch at YC you know
there were only eight companies it was a
really small community I use the Wayback
Machine to actually see what reddit
looked like in its earliest days
it hasn't changed that much but if you
look closely this is actually before
they called up boats up boats they were
calling it booth
this is like 2005 and July so that's how
they got their very first users just
sharing it among their community of
founders and so you know what I
recommend you do is share the product
with your friends and family watch them
use it you know sit down next to them
and ask for feedback but don't stay in
this phase for too long because your
friends and family might not be the
exact right you know ideal user for your
product or what you're building and so
sometimes their feedback isn't quite as
helpful as a real users is so for
example you know if Alexis and Steve had
show this with their parents their
parents might have been like what the
hell is this so you get you know get out
of that you know family and friends
circuit as fast as you can and so the
next move would be to launch to
strangers so one of my favorite examples
of a YC company launching launching to
strangers is the company lug so lug is
an app that lets you call movers and
delivery people on demand so even before
lug had built a fully functioning app or
product they would rent a truck and they
would go drive to Ikea and they would
sit outside of Ikea so they would watch
shoppers and they'd look people who were
having a particularly difficult time
tying stuff to the top of their cars and
they'd run up to those customers and
they'd say like hey instead of trying to
tie this you know mattress on top of
your car wouldn't it be cool if you
could just push a button and someone
with a truck would come and help do this
for you and you know the customers would
be like sweating and then be like yes
that's exactly what I need at this
moment and you know they'd hit they
download the app they click the Lugg
button and then the founder would run
back to the parking lot drive up in his
truck and then the customer be like oh
my god it's you and they were like yeah
you know so it was a real hustle at the
beginning like none of this was working
on the back end but it really confirmed
for them that this was a hair on fire
problem for their users and customers
and so they decided it makes sense for
us to really build this out and spend
time you know on this product so
launching to strangers will help do that
for you it will help show you whether
people are actually willing to download
and pay for what it is you're building
we'll talk about online communities this
is actually one of my favorite ways to
launch um
I think you should plan a launch for
every single community that you are part
so when a company goes through Y
Combinator they have the option of
launching on Bookface before they launch
publicly so Bookface is our internal
platform at YC it's like Facebook meets
LinkedIn meets Cora and there are
currently over 4,000 you know other
founders on book base so it's a fairly
low risk way to launch because it's it's
not totally public but there are you
know is enough of an audience there to
get some feedback and you're launching
in front of you know fairly friendly
people who you know want to see you
succeed
and so they launched there and what I
think you guys are particularly lucky
because you have startup school and you
have the startup school forum which
about forty thousand founders are on so
if you have an early version of your
product there is literally no reason
that you shouldn't be launching to the
startup school community in the next few
weeks and so you know I also think that
founders and other people making and
building stuff they give the best early
product feedback so you have thousands
of other founders at your disposal so I
think that you know that this you know
kind of gives you a leg up here here's a
sort of extreme example of a company
that successfully launched in online
communities so magic is an on-demand
personal assistant when they started in
Y Combinator in 2015 they were actually
building a blood pressure monitoring app
so they were trying to get this blood
pressure monitoring app to grow and it
wasn't growing as quickly as they were
hoping so they decided you know let's
test out another idea that we had so
they sent a link around for their
friends and family and it just looked
like this it basically said like Texas
phone number and we'll make anything
happen like magic like it was very very
basic and their friend one of their
friends thought it was so cool that they
shared it on reddit and hacker news and
basically overnight like over the course
of a weekend 40,000 people signed up to
use magic and so of course they were
like oh my god this is crazy and and
let's you know let's be honest this is
an extreme case and almost no-one who
launches on Reddit and hacker news is
going to get 40,000 users overnight but
my point is it's definitely worth
putting yourself out there because you
know you might be one of those like
extreme cases but at the very least
you'll get some early users and you'll
get some
great feedback I'm so many of the strips
that go through YC launched on Hacker
News and producthunt
and you know we over time have looked at
the stats of how well these launches
convert so you know a TechCrunch launch
versus a product hunt launch versus a
hacker news launch and in terms of
converting to users and you know they're
starting to even out in terms of their
impact and conversion for you know
whether it's you know your signups or
you know converting to customers so um
if you're launching in these communities
and aren't active members of these
communities yet I my suggestion is that
you spend a little bit of time looking
at the communities you understand the
rules especially if you're if you're
posting to subreddits right they all
sort of have their own moderators have
their own rules understand the best way
to talk to to these communities and if
it's a community that's known for being
helpful ask for advice ask for feedback
and if you're not part of these
communities I'd reach out to someone who
is and ask them for advice ask them for
the best way to launch because they're
going to be tips for every community and
you know for example one company in this
batch you know was building something
that he wanted to get more you know
women's perspectives on and and there -
Mel founders and one of the users of
alpha which is a community for women and
tech said hey I'll post that too you
know for it to alpha for you and I'll
tell you what kind of feedback they got
so I recommend like connecting with
someone in the community and asking them
for help if you're not part of the
community yourself the biggest piece of
advice I have for launching on online
communities is write like you talk do
not talk like a marketing robot people
hate that so don't use marketing
language or deep jargon talk like a
human one year when you're addressing
the communities so all you need and
these you know when you introduce
yourself in these posts introduce
yourself talk about what you're building
talk briefly about why you're doing it
or how you came across the problem
people on hacker news for example are
super intellectually curious so are
there any interesting insights that
you've learned from talking to potential
users or your users is there anything
surprising or delightful that you could
share with the community because people
love that and they also want to ask you
questions but sometimes don't know
exactly how or which questions they
should ask you
so tee it up for them say hey I'm an
expert in X Y & Z and I'm happy to
answer questions on these topics
otherwise you risk people going down all
sorts of weird rabbit holes but so and
just make sure like that you're sort of
are sharing this community asking and
asking them for advice try to cut down
as much of the jargon and marketing as
possible out of these pitches the
request for access launch the magic
story that I share with you actually
reminded me of this other type of launch
you can do so when magic launched you
know overnight they got 40,000 people
signing up and of course they couldn't
serve 40,000 users immediately so they
launched a wait list and they also gave
people ways to skip the line so for
example if you tweeted about magic you'd
get you know to skip a few spots in line
so you can build these viral elements
into your launches that will help get
people to spread the word for you one of
my current favorite examples of this
request for access launch is super human
so super human is building a better
email experience so you can go to their
site here and request access and you can
also ask a current user to refer you and
then that'll help you skip the line so
in the signature of all emails that are
sent by superhuman users is a little tag
that says sent by superhuman and so I'm
a superhuman user and I get a ton of
emails like I'll send a ton out of of my
emails out to people and I get a ton of
emails asking me for referrals you know
people I am email say hey how did you
like superhuman
would you mind referring to the product
so if you have a product that you can
build the sort of viral element into I
highly recommend it so we don't have a
huge amount of time because like
obviously social media and launching to
bloggers is this huge long and well
covered topic but I I wanted to skim
them briefly and give you an example of
a company that we worked with that did
it very well as most of you know
launching two popular blogs that cover
your industry or trade can be incredibly
powerful so joy is a free wedding
website builder and they were
one of the fastest-growing companies in
their batch and a lot of their early
growth like an alarming amount of their
really early growth was due to being
placed on a number of lists like this
they essentially googled they looked at
you know SEO and they googled you know
best wedding website builders and
figured out who was coming up on you
know the first couple pages of results
on Google and they reached out to all
those bloggers and you know they said
hey we have this new product you know we
think your community but love it would
you be willing to add us to this list
and they you know they said that they
reached out and basically did a drip
campaign to over 50 you know 50 bloggers
and only got responses from four but
those four responses made a huge impact
for their early growth and so one note
that I want you to keep in mind is that
some bloggers and influence or
opportunities are pay-to-play and joy
did not pay early on and I do not want
you paying early on either if folks are
asking you to pay please find other or
creative routes to get around this
because as startups as early-stage
showed up you just don't have you don't
have the money to do it and so I'm say
it is definitely possible to go this
route without paying a ton of money so
figure out you know
wait routes around the expensive sort of
sponsorship dollars if you're a hardware
or physical product of course you can do
a pre-order campaign and so you know
honestly be a whole presentation of its
own but take a look at some successful
campaigns and get a sense for how they
built out their launch strategy so for
example sheer text was a company in YC
that was making unbreakable sheer
pantyhose the founder Katherine made a
great really compelling video that you
pitched press she launched on Hacker
News where you know hacker news is
probably you know it's a very male
audience so we were curious how how they
would respond to something like sheer
you know unbreakable pantyhose but they
loved it they thought it was very clever
they thought you know that the technical
piece behind it was really interesting
and you know so I would recommend like
any company you know try to launch and
see how different communities respond
she launched a product hunt she
her friends and family and batchmates
and investors to help spread the word
and she did an incredibly successful
campaign and so of course there's a new
feature or new product line launches so
two very different companies that do
this incredibly well are stripe and
glossier so both companies are
incredibly smart about how they launch
new products so stripe has always been
great from the very beginning they've
been really great at engaging the
community so every time they launch a
product so for example when they launch
stripe Atlas they launched it on Hacker
News and the founders were in the thread
talking to all you know potential users
and and talking about the product and
why they were launching it um the
problems that they felt it was solving
they blogged about it they spread the
word on social media they pitched press
and this is something that they do over
and over again if you look at stripes
blog if you look at hacker news you can
kind of see the history since the
beginning they've been very great at
said of activating the community
glossier which is a you know a beauty
brand is incredible at launching new
product and the way they think about it
is actually very scientific they release
products at on a very specific cadence
at specific intervals and for every
product they essentially hit every
single launch button again and again so
communities social media press
advertising so each time this they you
know this new product launches which is
basically like every six to eight weeks
they have this cycle going so there's a
constant drumbeat about glossier out in
you know out in the world one last note
before we jump into questions is while
you're in start-up school you should
start to build your own communities and
you this you can do this even really pre
product so there was one YC founder
Gaddy Avron who is founder Symetra and
he had a really particularly successful
TechCrunch launch a TechCrunch launch is
you know a story about what they were
doing launched in TechCrunch and I
noticed that they had a ton of shares a
ton of engagement so I asked him to
share you know how did you know how did
you set this up what did you do to share
and spread the word about your launch
and he said that over the years you know
even before launching the product he
started to build his own email list so
every person he met that
discussed his startup with even you know
even very loosely he would add them to
an email list and they would get you
know sort of email updates about what he
was working on on a semi-regular like I
said my regular intervals so when the
TechCrunch article came out he said he
sent that email to the list full of all
the people that he'd you know he'd ever
talked to other startup founders
investors friends family and asked for
their help in spreading the news and he
said the response was significant and
he's even saw VCS who hadn't invested in
them sharing the story from their own
personal Twitter accounts and he said
you know you would be really surprised
by who comes out of the woodwork to help
when you ask for it so I would recommend
while you're in start-up school you have
the opportunity to talk to so many
people about what you're building and
start and ask them hey can I add you to
my update list and over time you know
that you'll get that into the hundreds
maybe maybe even thousands so I would
definitely recommend that you start
doing that now and so to sum up I want
you to stop thinking about launching as
this one moment in time I don't want you
to spend all of start-up school getting
ready for this one big day this one big
launch day that you're trying to line up
all these things for this is something
that is a continuous process that you
can do over the course of the next
couple months and into the lifecycle of
your company if you didn't catch them
the first time these are all the
opportunities that we went over and I'm
cat so if you ever have any questions
it's demo day is coming up so it might
be slightly slower than usual to respond
but you can always reach out to cat at Y
Combinator and I'm also on Twitter we
have ten minutes for questions so does
anyone have any questions about launches
yes the red shirt
so the question is uh what do you think
about launch parties oh gosh I mean as
an early stage startup I wouldn't I
wouldn't necessarily recommend you spend
a ton of money right like back in the
day I don't know like back in the I
worked at Wired magazine right out of
school and people were spending like
tens of thousands of dollars on these
elaborate launch parties and it's
bananas and I would not recommend anyone
do that but at the same time if you if
you want to have something small and you
know if you especially if you have a
community and you want to celebrate you
know I'm you know sure why not but I
would not spend a ton of money on launch
parties wouldn't do it but I'm not gonna
stop you if you want to do something
smart and and fun it's in the front so
the the question is if you have
different ideas and you're trying to
test out different ideas or different
approaches to solving a problem how do
you recommend launching it and and so
you know I think you could definitely
say you have two different ideas and
you're trying to kind of can you what
what industry just really quickly okay
so so I would say this is a case of like
where it's really important to talk to
your users really quickly so so getting
in front of you know potential customers
and you're launching to not just friends
and family but potential customers and
asking them like what it is they want
what what approach do they think would
help them best and getting those like
talking to customers getting in front of
those users as quickly as possible will
help kind of got in which direction to
go in but that is a case where I
definitely think it's it's better to to
launch sooner and even just you know
pitching the idea to your customers
yes that's a good question so the
question is if you were launching on
Hacker News what types of companies are
better suited to launch on Hacker News
b2b consumer dev tools so the hacker
news community is you know a lot of very
smart technical people but you would be
surprised so I would recommend you go to
if you go to news dot y combinator comm
slash launches you can see a list or
even show HN you'll see a list of all
the companies slash launches will show
you a list of all the YC companies that
have launched show HN is is all general
companies that have sort of shared what
they're building on HN and I think you'd
be surprised by which companies get the
most up votes so I'm one of the top YC
companies of all time that launched on
hacker news in terms of votes and
engagement was a company called 70
million jobs and it was a solo
non-technical founder building a company
that would help get people you know had
criminal records and had previously been
in jail connecting them with jobs and
the community really loved what what the
founder was building and asked a lot of
questions and really um and we're really
really engaged so the happen when I've
asked this question to the hacker news
moderators they're like you know I
always thought you know sort of before I
talk to them that Deb tools right like
something very technical would do best
on Hacker News and they said that's
absolutely not true if you actually look
at the numbers all sorts of companies
and do well and but what does really
well on hacker news is really lean
leaning into the intellectual curiosity
like is there something really
interesting that you've learned from
your users that you can share with the
community is there something surprising
or um you know that they might not have
heard elsewhere and so that's that's one
Commendation I'd have there is it
doesn't matter what industry you are but
really try to speak to the community in
a way that will kind of connect with
them and then I would look at previous
launches that have done well and see how
they've described themselves and how
they've kind of teed up the communities
to start asking questions
oh really depends so on what I would
recommend with reddit is you you target
a subreddit that is very specific to so
reddit has a lot like millions of
different subreddits on every single
topic so you can find subreddits on you
know TV shows all the way to like
fitness and to men's fashion advice and
history buffs and and so what I would do
is I would figure out what is the
subreddit that you want to target first
and then that the demographics are going
to be different depending on what a
subreddit you go after but of course
it's like on average it's probably like
younger male audience but yeah there are
even subreddit sent like only women are
part of so it really depends okay one
more question in the green keep it short
yeah I think I mean I think in for your
landing page you want it to be really
clear what it is you're building and who
it is you're building for um but once
you you know start getting you know into
too much detail I think it can get
really it can get muddied or confusing
and you can you can certainly add a
little bit more detail than just that
but I would keep copy really tight like
people people's attention spans are
really short these days and and I think
it's if you can kind of and you have a
huge community here to help you AV test
that messaging and that and that you
know kind of that front page copy so but
I would recommend to keep it as short
and succinct as possible okay
you
you